- We should start a support group.
(laughs)
- I'm telling you, we really should
- There are some days
I just bust out crying.
I didn't know,
I'm touch-starved.
You know, I'm touch-starved.
I need to be touched
and I'm not saying where,
but I'm just telling you.
- (laughs)
- I'm so Kelly, like,
this thing, I I'm, you know
Being single, I've gotten okay with,
but I'm touch-starved too.
I'm so touch-starved,
I told Kim I'm attracted
to the guy that she likes.
- I, (laughs)
That's like a no, no.
- I did--
- No, no, no, tell them about the trainer,
forget the guy.
We workout together
and, tell them about
the self-defense class
and what you did, tell them.
- So, Kelly, we take a self
defense class with our trainer,
you know, for women to,
if anything ever happened.
So you know how to, you know,
defend yourself.
- I wanna take this with y'all
- It is the best class for women.
- Yep, Andre is really good,
we're gonna put you on there.
We should, we should put
her on a zoom or something,
we should put Kelly on then
she can workout with us.
- I would totally do that.
- Or like when we come out of COVID,
you got to take the class with us but
you know, he teaches us how to,
how to, if, if we fall on the ground,
which most people do when
they're costed, how to take,
how to defend yourself on the ground,
if they're straddling you.
So it requires you to thrust your hips up,
to thrust them off,
to do a few moves.
- I got it.
So Kim is with the trainer
and she goes, well,
let me get this right.
I have to thrust up, move my hips,
move it around.
Let me try it again, thrust up,
move my hips, move it around,
wait a minute, one more time.
I'm not done thrust--
- We're talking about you,
how did it get to me?
- So the trainer says, Kelly to her,
he goes,
you're taking too long.
I got to go to the bathroom.
She then accosted the trainer
- I didn't accost him, I
didn't understand, I told you.
I was slow in instructions in school
and I need to know exactly
thrust up, twist, thrust up.
I kept thrusting because I got a bad back
and it wasn't as strong as you
with your horse legs.
Just cause you got horse
legs and a horse booty.
- You know, Kim is teasing
me about my legs because
I have very strong legs.
- I do too
- So we had to learn self
defense on the ground.
You have to wrap your legs around.
We had to wrap our legs around
the trainer to flip him over,
which I was able to do.
It felt a little good to
dig my heels into his butt.
I am going to say
that felt great.
(laughter)
He was flipping me all
around and I did say to him,
you got to be magnificent after dark.
This is amazing.
- No, no. Tell the truth, tell the truth
No, no, no, Kelly, she's lying.
She tripped, she, okay,
She flipped the trainer and then
she spooned him for five minutes
- Spooned him?
- She was like oh,
I'm so tired I can't get off the ground.
And she hugged on him, because
she's touch-starved and then,
she was not. We were on
concrete! She laid there.
- When you're on concrete
it's cold, that's like --
- I did, I did, I did spoon him, Kelly.
I, I, after we finished all
of that, I needed a cigarette
and a spoon. I spooned him
and we, and we kind of took
a little bit of a nap.
- [Kelly] God this guy